but people I think have always gone to
extremes to meet ladies cuz Samuel
Jackson when you were you in college
yeah you did something quite extreme to
meet ladies I wasn't yeah I became a
cheerleader now see that's what yeah now
see that seems quite an out-there thing
to do well meet a woman well it wasn't
necessarily just to meet a woman it was
so I could travel to all the places that
the team went to meet women yeah mark I
was going to all these other schools and
hey but did you pom-poms and stuff I had
a megaphone yeah the girls had pom-poms
but I was in all-male school across the
street was an all-woman School Spellman
so we got our chili to our female
cheerleaders from there so I was the
only a volunteered to be a cheerleader
that year so I taught my roommate into
doing it and you this is awesome we get
to pick all the girls so we picked them
and we got to travel all these other
schools to meet women which was totally
dope oh my god great well such a flare
but did you have to do cheerleading did
you have to do the chances we did some
cheers but basically we would go I mean
my roommate now will go hey gang hey
gang and then the girls would do to
cheer Nate do some flips and we play
what we weren't picking them up a
holding them up yeah that's it you know
second hey gang yeah basically it you
know every now and then we do you know
some chairs like you know Edward Edward
he's our man if he can't do it it
now you know it's the sea and stark and
skinny-dipping so Oh have some fun
oh thank you shut up ographers
miss the moment when Kanye broke a smile
no no they did not that did not happen I
would say there's a follow-up